se vienen louis los octavos de la final
de la uefa champions league y lo que ya
adelantaba el sorteo dejó a dos equipos
que estaban llamados a estar presente en
la final como lo es el real madrid y el
parís saint germain el duelo ha ganado
más connotación luego que por un error
el sorteo debió repetirse y dejó así la
confrontación en el partido pone frente
a frente a lionel messi y a su ex máximo
rival como lo es el real madrid será la
segunda vez que ambos equipos se vean la
cara en octavos de final en la primera
ocasión fue en la temporada 2017 2018 y
en aquel entonces el real madrid salió
vencedor en líneas generales el saldo es
favorable para el conjunto blanco a lo
largo del torneo puesto que se han visto
dos veces en fase de grupos pero
escuchemos que dijeron los técnicos de
ambos equipos previo al compromiso
creo que
no hay favorito
creo que es una eliminatoria que podría
también ser una final de champions por
nombres por jugadores por calidad
pero que parecen ser mención a más de 50
años esperando ganar este título tiene
la expiración como nosotros de ganarla
esta competición podría ser una final
hoy nadie se podía sorprender de esto
nada la tenemos las ganas de
eliminar o rival que puede competir para
ganar la champions league como ya
habíamos adelantado mes y volverá a
verse contra su ex rival en la liga
española de fútbol lo ha visto en 45
partidos dos de ellos han sido por la
champions league le anotados 26 goles y
dos de ellos ha sido por el máximo
torneo de clubes este el continente
europeo pero en otro partido de la
jornada el sporting de portugal estará
recibiendo la visita del manchester
city- recordemos que el chiste fue
finalista en la pasada edición del
torneo